Welcome back.
The debate rages on between which is the better smartphone, Android phones or iPhones.
But one company in China may have just thrown a third option into the mix.
It's called the GooApple.
The iPhone: Considered a marvel of the modern age.
Elegant and refined.
A streamlined finish and a cute little Android on the back.
GooApple?
That's right. It seems there's a new rip-off of the iPhone hitting the markets in China.
It looks like an iPhone,...
...it feels like an iPhone,...
...but it's not an iPhone.
Products like these are known as shanzhai bootlegs.
Shanzhai literally means in Chinese, "mountain stronghold".
It's a reference to historical warlord hideouts that existed outside government control.
Though you can be sure Genghis Khan never had one of these.
It runs on Android 2.2...
...but has been heavily modified to look like a typical iPhone OS.
The GooApple, a mash-up of Google and Apple, is expected to go for about 200 US dollars.
Steve Jobs offered no comments.